An international search and rescue team is racing to find a missing Submersible,
carrying five people who disappeared during a trip to the deep sea remains of the Titanic
shipwreck operated by Ocean gate expeditions.
The Submersible called the Titan launched from ST John's Newfoundland on Sunday
but nearly two hours into its roughly eight hour expedition,
the craft lost contact with a research vessel on the surface.
Our crews are working around the clock to ensure that we are doing everything
possible to locate the Titan.
The Titan which was carrying four crew and a pilot weighs £21,000 and can
travel more than 13,000 ft beneath the surface.
The vessel is designed to sustain 96 hours of emergency oxygen.
As of Tuesday afternoon,
the people aboard had about 40 hours of the oxygen left.
According to the US Coast Guard,
it all depends on your oxygen conservation activities.
If you get people to achieve a low
metabolic oxygenation practice,
then you can stretch that oxygen out and that increases your chances of survival.
The search involving aircraft and surface vessels was intensifying about 900 miles
east of Cape Cod near the site of the Titanic wreckage.
This is a complex search effort which requires multiple agencies with subject matter,
expertise and specialized equipment.
The challenging part is getting there and of course the planet,
you know,
the the five passengers aboard include British aviator and
explorer Hamish Harding who went to space on a blue origin rocket in 2022
Shazad Dawood,
a member of one of Pakistan's richest families and his son,
Suleiman Dawood,
Paul Henri Nao,
a French explorer who is considered a leading authority on the Titanic and Stockton
Rush,
the founder and chief executive of Ocean.
The company was founded in 2009 and began offering tours to the Titanic's Rack in
2021 in a 2022 CBS news report.
Rush provided a tour of the Titan and what he described as its off the shelf components.
I got these from Camper World.
We run the whole thing with this game controller.
The expedition's aim was to take high definition photos and video of history's most famous
shipwreck and capture data to track the ship's decay.
You're dealing with a surface search and a sub surface search and frankly,
that makes it an incredibly complex operation.